- Do you have those shoes
in your closet right now?
- I might.
Lemme see.
- Yes.
- I definitely have
a shoe storage.
It's a problem.
I don't have that.
But I do have a pair of these.
These are some of my—
- Oh!
- My faves.
- Yes!
Did we just become best friends?
- I think we just did.
- Welcome to “Full-Bodied,” where,
as the wine gets darker,
the questions get deeper.
We are here with one of the best
basketball players of all time.
Absolute Hall of Famer
whenever she retires.
The style icon, the
sneaker god and, to me, one
of the coolest people I've had
the pleasure of working with:
Sue Bird, the one, the only.
[Cork popping]
- Ahhh.
- We're here at Résonance, one
of my favorite vineyards,
top five most beautiful
vineyards in Oregon.
And they make wines
that match the view.
First of all, cheers.
Thank you for doing this.
I wanted to bring
this bottle to you
because it is from North
Fork of Long Island, which
is your hood.
And, to be honest, I don't really
drink a lot of sauvignon blanc.
But I like this.
- Yeah, it's good.
- Right? I would drink this, right?
It's citrusy. It's
refreshing. It's
like, if I was by the
pool, and it was hot,
I'd be like, “All right,” right?
It's easy on the palate.
I'm just curious: What is in
the water in Long Island that
made you as badass as you are?
- I think it's one
of those things,
like, if I had an
exact answer for you,
I'd be, like, bottling it up.
I'd be putting it in a bottle.
I would get a fancy oxygen
thing, and I would sell it.
No, I think all the
winning is just about—
yes, you have to be, obviously,
talented and skilled
and all these things to
get to a certain level.
But I really—it's
gonna sound so corny,
but I really have always put the
team's success ahead of mine.
And I found that all the
success I could ever want
comes when we win.
And now, I'm at a
place in my career,
partly because of my
age and my experience,
where I can really
help other people.
I can really help my teammates.
And I can really help
them be their best.
And then I just ride
them, to be honest.
I'm like, “Take me
to the motherland.
Let's go!”
So I've been lucky to
have really good teammates
along the way too.
- You have so many championships
and so many Olympic gold
medals.
Which one was the one
where you were like, “OK,
I have to dig deep”?
- It's probably—the one that's
freshest is we won in 2018.
And it's definitely Seattle,
because in the WNBA,
like, similar to the NBA, it's like,
it’s hard to win in this league.
Like, some of it's luck.
And the competition is so close
that in a series, usually
the best team wins.
But, like, you never know.
- [Announcer:] Bird connects!
It's Sue Bird's building!
- So in 2018, this is, like,
probably, to be honest, like,
the best moment of my career.
Like, no joke.
For it to happen when I was
38 is, like, the crazy part.
But we played
Phoenix in the semis.
It was a five-game
series, and it was Game 5.
I ended up scoring, like, 14
or so points in the final five
or six minutes.
- [Announcer:] Bird heaves!
- [Bird:] And it—
- [Frye:] Dang!
- Yeah, it was, like, a close game, and
it kinda sealed the game.
- [Announcer:] Sue Bird!
It is her night!
- So that was the one where, like,
you talk about digging deep—
- Yeah.
- There was drama.
You know, it was Game 5.
We've just, like, you know, went to war
with them for four games.
And now this is the fifth game.
Diana Taurasi has never
lost, literally never lost
in an elimination game.
So it's like, all this
stuff is swirling.
I had broken my nose
the game before.
There was just, like,
a lot going on.
So that one, that
one sticks out.
- Just seeing the pedigree of
basketball that you have,
right, and the winningest—
like, I respect winning
more than anything else
because I understand
how hard it is.
We've both seen
players and people
come where you go, “You have
everything. Everything!”
Like, “You can shoot. You
can jump. You're smart.”
And it's just like their
motivation for being great
is, like, an outboard motor on
a big yacht of talent, right?
- Yeah. [Laughing]
- This second one, it
is a white Burgundy.
And so this is a Premier
cru, which is, like,
higher level of wine.
And to be from Burgundy,
right, is to be elite
and to be the best.
And why it's elite is
not only where it's from,
but how they make it and
how they're more hands-off.
And they allow their wine—
and the simplicities
of it take over.
There's only a few, couple of
people that can do Burgundies.
- Listen, if you want greatness,
you gotta work for it, OK?
[Cork popping]
- Oh, there we go.
That's the best
sound in the world.
- Got it.
- So while you're pouring that—
- Whew, that was close.
- I would like to
know two things.
No. 1, who
are the top, let's
say, three to five players
you've ever played against?
And then who are your
top three to five players
you love watching?
- OK.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
Now, you taste the difference
between the other one
and this one?
- Yeah, definitely.
If it was gross,
I would tell you.
- Yeah, please, please tell me.
- They’re really good.
- If it's gross—
- Please tell me.
Then it's somebody else's fault.
- Best players I’ve played against—
Diana Taurasi, for sure.
- OK.
- Lauren Jackson.
- Breanna Stewart.
I'm definitely biased.
Those three are my teammates.
- Yeah.
- So I had front-row
seats to the greatness.
The next two, I would go...
dang.
So I'm gonna pick guards,
because, playing against.
So every time I got
switched in some capacity
on to Sheryl Swoopes, lowkey,
I was like, “Ohhh, fuck.”
- Oh, yeah.
- Can we curse on this?
- You were like, “Bring that help,” right?
- Yeah.
- You were like, “What
side? What side?”
- I was like, “Ohhh, crap.”
And then actually,
the fifth player,
I could go Lindsay Whalen,
give some love to another point
guard.
- Yep.
- But I'm actually gonna go
Cynthia Cooper, just because,
again—
- Wow.
- She only played
in the league when
I was in the league for, like, 10 games.
- Right.
- She had retired, and she
came back for this one year.
It happened to be my
second year in the league.
And she only got to, like—
I don't remember exactly—
10, 15 games.
But I was one of the, we were one
of the games that we played.
And so it was, it was amazing to play
against a legend, you know?
She had started the league.
Raise the roof,
that was her thing.
- What about on the men's side?
- Stephon Marbury.
- Yeah, Steph.
- He was exciting to watch.
- He was exciting
to be a teammate.
- Yeah.
Jimmer Fredette. Does he count?
- Jimmer!
Yes!
- I mean, he's fun to
watch cuz he's
the kinda guy
where you're like,
“Oh, this guy's been
dropping 40 in college?”
Like, “Let's see
what he's about.”
That kind of—you know?
- We're gonna take
a hard left, OK?
- OK.
- So when did you become
addicted to sneakers?
This is actually
an intervention.
- I feel like the
world should know
I do have it under control.
I'm acknowledging
the addiction, but—
no, I bet it's a similar story.
I'm sure you have
a ton of sneakers
just from, like,
being an athlete.
You just get a bunch of stuff.
I, like, literally woke up one day,
and I was like, “Oh, wow. I
have a collection.”
But it wasn’t—I wasn't, like, going out of my
way to, like, stand on the line
somewhere.
- Right, right, right.
- I wasn't hitting my
Nike rep constantly.
It was just like,
they've done a good job
of getting us the good stuff.
And now, it's, like, kind
of part of our culture.
- Right.
- It wasn't when
you think about it.
It wasn't, especially
for a woman.
It wasn't, like, five years ago.
So I always joke, I've
been, like, waiting for the day—
- Yeah.
- For sneakers to be
appropriate to wear to, like,
a black-tie event.
I've been waiting for this day.
- See, my kick game
is lowkey only good
because I was in the
league so long, all of Nike
felt bad for me.
And when I moved to Portland, I
know where they all live, so I
bug 'em. Shoutout, Ted.
And so, you know, for me—
- You're at the
employee store like—
- I'm always like, “Hey”—yeah, oh,
they’re like,
“Channing, dammit!
Hide the 18s.”
So there's only so many cool
shoes you can get in a size 18.
So, you know, I've been kinda hampered.
Wait till you see the
kicks I got on right now.
Could you guess what they are?
- Maybe not-so-fresh
pair of Air Force 1s.
That would be my guess.
- No.
No, here, watch these bad boys.
Look, these are a fresh
pair of Croc Air Force 1s.
- [Laughing] Oh, Croc—hey, got
the UGG slippers.
- Do you?
OK!
Listen, sometimes, you gotta
let the big dogs breathe now.
Look—
- Yeah, cozy. Gotta be cozy.
- What is it about
sneakers that you love?
And what is it, like, about your
favorite pair that you love?
Is it the exclusivity?
Is it the colorway?
Is it the story?
What is that?
- So, like, my favorite
pairs are more the story.
One of my all-time
favorite pairs,
and I have, like, my originals—
- Right.
- Well, actually, no,
that's not entirely true.
I don't have, like,
the O-O-OG version.
I have, like, when it
came out the second time.
It's since come out, like,
three and four times.
The Andre Agassis.
They're like the—
- Yes!
Oh, the tennis joints!
- Air [Tech] Challenges. Yeah,
with the pink on the side.
I remember getting those
in, like, elementary school.
When they came out again and
I could get them as an adult,
those are the same
ones I still have.
And so, like, those are the ones
that I hold on to tight.
- Growing up in Arizona, like, remember
when Charles Barkley came out
with the CB 34s with
the first air bubble?
- Those are my favorite—
those are, like, one of my first
and one of my favorite
basketball shoes.
- Yes!
- Like, obsessed.
- So I could not—
I was crying to
my dad. Like, “Dad,
please let me get these shoes.”
He was like, “Dude.”
So in sixth grade, I
was 6'2" wearing, like—
- Damn.
- You know—how old are
you in sixth grade, 12?
Wearing a size 13, 14
shoe in Chuck Taylors.
- That's crazy.
- But you know Chucks
run big, right?
- Yeah.
- So, like, I was wearing a 14
because my dad was like, “Well,
you're gonna grow into 'em.”
- “You’re gonna grow into ‘em.”
- So imagine—
- Aw.
- Yeah!
- Damn.
- I was getting roasted—
- Yeah, I bet.
- Roasted at school back in
the '90s, with my big clippy
cloppy flippers.
But, man, it's just like,
sneakers are evolving.
And they're awesome, and
they have these stories.
But just those original shoes
that you fell in love with
are unreal.
- Yeah.
So it's funny you say
that, because my favorite,
by far, like, all-time
favorite basketball shoe
is the original Uptempos.
Like—
- Oh!
- And about, I dunno,
a year ago or so,
I was like, “Let me
work out in these.”
Like, these are some
of my favorite shoes.
Like, lemme go work out.
Oh, I had to take ‘em
off in, like, 20 minutes.
I was like, “These
are unwearable.”
I feel like our feet
are now a little, a little snobby.
We're very—
- Do you have those shoes
in your closet right now?
- I might.
Lemme see.
- Yes.
- I don't know.
Yeah, I definitely
have a shoe storage.
It's a problem.
- Yeah, well, I got wine storage—
- I don’t know if I have ‘em here.
- So it's a problem, too.
- Let me see what I can
break out, though.
All right, I don't, I don’t have that.
But I do have a pair of these.
These are some of my—
- Oh!
- My faves.
- Yes!
I hooped in those my
senior year in college.
This is before I tell—
so nobody tell Bron.
Nobody show Bron.
But I literally loved
playing in those.
I thought I could jump—it
actually helped me get drafted.
You know, you gotta fake
it to make it sometimes.
- Yep. They're so comfortable
- Any shoe with a strap is perfect.
- Same!
- Same.
- Oh, my goodness. Did we
just become best friends?
- I think we just did.
- We can open up these
red bottles now.
And so why we picked
this—obviously
Ponzi has been around
Portland and obviously
Willamette Valley
for a long time.
And the winery owners are
women, powerful women.
- Yeah, I saw that.
- Wonderful, awesome,
awesome people.
And so they are just
doing things together
where they are
supporting human rights
and making sure that everyone
is gonna be treated equally.
I will say this: You
have done so much for not
only inside the WNBA
and using your platform,
but just all walks of life.
I would consider you a leader.
I would consider you one
of the forefront of that.
And that is a big
responsibility.
So how do you take that?
How did that come about?
- I have this, like, interesting
career just because I've
been playing for so long.
So when I entered the league,
the league was different.
The world was different. Society
was different. All that stuff.
- Oh, yeah.
- So when I first got
into the league,
and really, most of
my career—like,
10-plus years—it just—
we had this vibe of like,
“Be thankful that
you can even play.”
- Right.
- You know, “Don't really push the limits.
Don't speak on these things.”
It wasn't that somebody
told me not to do it.
It was just, like, a vibe.
I kind of, like, understood
what was happening.
And so I didn't.
- Very oppressive vibe?
- Yeah.
- You can say that.
- I think a combination
of things—one,
just getting older,
more experience,
getting more confident
in, like, who you are.
A lot of that has to do
with when I came out.
That's a big part of, like,
saying who you are.
- Right.
- It just, it gives you this
whole other confidence.
So some of it's just, like,
natural progression of life.
Some of it is meeting Megan.
And I think what you see now is
just someone who feels like—
I don't regret the early parts
of my career. In some ways,
I don't know that I was ready.
There are, you know, things
that need to be said.
And I have a lot of the
experience that I can draw on.
And I just don't wanna
miss another moment, right?
Like, I feel like I missed a lot
of opportunities in the past,
so I just don't wanna
miss them anymore.
And that's kind of, I think,
what you see now from me.
- What is something that the
men can do to uplift you guys,
and to, like, be hand in hand?
- These are, like, kind of
tough questions.
I don't know that I
have exact answers.
I would say—I do think
language is important.
It's not just how we're
empowering our daughters,
which we should.
- Yeah.
- It's not just how we're
encouraging our daughters,
which we should.
It's also what we're
teaching our sons.
- Right, right.
- Because those are gonna
be the next generation.
It's like, you have to come from
a place of willing to learn
and willing to, like, maybe
at times, in that growth
and in that—
- Evolution?
- Yeah, evolution, and, like,
the more knowledge
you gain. Also,
kind of understanding
maybe the privilege
you've had, or maybe
the things you've said in the
past that weren't, you know, on the up
and up and just kind of, like,
acknowledging that. Not getting
defensive, but just
acknowledging it
and then, like, fixing
it and moving on.
It's kind of like when you
tell a white person, “You
had privilege,” for
some reason, it's like
this reaction of like,
“No, I worked hard,”
you know what I mean?
- Yes.
- And it's like, “Yeah, no—”
- Oh, yeah.
I live in Portland, trust me.
- Yeah.
[Laughing] But it's like,
“Yeah, you did work hard.
I didn't say you
didn't work hard.
But you had—you
have privilege.
Like, you had a head start.”
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's a similar—it's similar.
It's not the same.
I'm not comparing in that
way, but, like, the lesson
is similar.
And then I think what you said
about the media is so crucial.
- Yeah.
- Giving women the airtime
and not just, like,
showing the highlight.
But I hope we get to a
point in our storytelling
where we're, like,
acknowledging the storylines
in women's sports.
- Yeah.
- And I think for women's sports,
we never tap into those,
so people never get invested the
way they are in men's sports.
It's like a small part
of it, but it matters.
- On that, on the youth of
the women of the WNBA,
where do you see it evolving in
the next five years, 10 years,
20 years?
Are you gonna be—and I'm
asking you personally, what is
that next goal?
Would you wanna be an owner?
Would you wanna be a coach?
- I don't know. That's
the short answer.
But—
- That’s aight.
- It's starting to become
a little more clear.
I do know that I wanna be—
I'm always gonna be
involved in women's sports.
So I'm sure you've
heard of Paige Bueckers.
She plays at Connecticut.
- Yeah. Oh, yeah.
- She's a freshman.
She's—
- Good gracious almighty.
- Yeah, insanely good.
Like, you can't deny it.
The best thing about her
and, like, her generation—
so there's a bunch of players.
Azzi Fudd's another
one. Hailey Van Lith.
I mentioned Caitlin Clark.
Like, they have these
followings right now.
I'm just saying like,
you, Channing Frye,
a former NBA player who's now
retired, knows her name.
And your kids—
- Oh, for sure.
I've watched a couple of games.
She's a walking bucket.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so people your
kids' age, or—
there's gonna be a
generation of people
that grow up with Paige.
And so when they become
the 24-, 25-year-old person
who can go out and buy a
ticket, who has a family,
Paige is gonna be a
household name already.
Like, it's starting earlier.
So in five years, I'm
really excited for where
women's basketball could be
because that era of player,
they already have a fanbase.
I had like, the UConn fanbase,
but it wasn't quite the same.
She's going to take that with
her for the next four years
and beyond.
Like I said, I don't know
exactly how it's going to look.
- Right. Right.
- But I can't imagine I'm not
involved in some way, shape
or form.
Like, ownership—I think
I'd be more likely to get
involved on the ownership side
than I would the coaching side.
I feel like coaching's
kind of hard.
- Oof.
No, thank you. No, thank you.
- And I feel like I
already lived this life.
I don't know if I want to live
it again. You know what I mean?
- We have a game, right?
And this—we'll end on this.
- OK.
- So since you have nothing
else to do tonight,
you've got to take
a sip for every time
you get it wrong, OK?
Here we go.
- I'm in.
- Right?
So it's called Fill
In the Grape, OK?
So we have five categories
with a question in each.
You're going to choose
your categories,
and then you have
to say the answer.
- OK.
- So it's Huskies in the W, Kicks,
History Books, WNBA Assists
or Megan.
- I'll go Huskies in the W.
- Name five UConn players who
play in the Western Conference.
- Breanna Stewart and
Katie Lou Samuelson.
- OK.
- Diana Taurasi, Moriah
Jefferson, Crystal Dangerfield.
Boom!
- You kicked my butt on that one.
- History Books sounds
like a wild card,
so I'll take History Books.
- Can you name two NBA
players—there's
only two NBA players who,
just like you, have won titles
in three different decades.
- I feel like LeBron has to be—
- Nope.
- No?
- No, uh huh.
- Tim Duncan?
- Yeah.
Now, he is a big man.
I think he went to Georgia Tech.
Somebody in my ear, tell me.
- He went to Georgia Tech?
- Very outgoing. It
was John Salley.
- Oh, John Salley.
The Best Damn—
- That's a name.
- The Best Damn Sports Show.
- Yes!
- How am I going to mess that up?
OK, we'll go Kicks.
- What sneakers did you wear when
you won your first championship
in 2004?
- Oh, the 2K4s, Huaraches.
- I knew.
I could have said that.
Everybody was playing in those!
- Everybody.
- Before you broke
the record in 2017,
who was the WNBA
all-time assist leader?
- Oh, Ticha Penicheiro.
- Ah, that's so easy.
Come on, guys!
- Yeah, these are easy.
You guys are lobbing them in.
Give me the Megan one.
- OK.
In 2019, against what team
or country did Megan convert
two penalty kicks in round of
16 to help the U.S. secure a win?
- Ah, see? Umm, France?
- Here we go, gotcha.
Take a little sippy sippy.
- Megan!
- [Laughing]
- You can phone a friend.
Ask her. See if she remembers.
- I think she's—Megan!
Maybe Sweden?
- OK, take one more sip.
- I don't know—
Germany?
I have no idea who they played.
- Ooh, take one more sip.
You gonna be lit, girl.
What you doing?
It's Tuesday!
Y'all watching The Voice?
It was Spain.
- Spain.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Aw, I told you.
Damn it.
- Yeah, I never would
have gotten it.
- Oh well.
Thank you for being a leader.
Thank you for taking the time.
Thank you for being awesome.
- Thank you so much for having me.
I had a good time.
- Another episode of “Full-Bodied.”This has been great. Sue Bird.